Hello.
This session is about
why do your AI agents disagree with
itself
and what to do about it.
And this is a Dyan Huang Lin, and you
can call me Dyan.
A little bit about my background.
My journey with AGI start from my PhD at
Imperial College London, where I was
working on continual learning.
Later, I worked with Professor Josh
Tenenbaum at MIT on one-shot learning,
meaning learning from one single
examples.
Afterwards, I was lucky that Alexa was
launching. I was the first three
appliance scientists on the question
answering team at the Alexa.
Later, attracted by a
startup working on AGI at the Silicon
Valley called Vicarious.
So, today Vicarious is part of the
Google DeepMind.
And there I got to work on the exciting
frontier research on zero-shot transfer
learning.
After working on AGI for a few years, I
decided to pivot to the applied world at
Zscaler,
which is cybersecurity company.
There I got to apply a variety of
different machine learning model to
adjust the cybersecurity challenge.
There for 5 years,
uh I decided to co-found my own company
because of pinpoint I have seen at the
Zscaler.
So, company is building AI agent to
auto-triage your security alerts
and which make your SOC more efficient.
Uh
we are super proud that Chrome innate
has been acquired by Data Dog earlier
this year. So now I'm part of the Data
Dog and leading the development of
self-evolved agent.
So today I'm going to share with you the
problem you're probably seeing your
day-to-day building AI agent.
The inconsistency.
Then we are discussed about where this
inconsistency come from in order to
figure out the solutions.
And we will discuss a few trade-off
among the different solutions and then
eventually we'll show you the
experimental results to show how
feasible they are.
You'll probably see this.
Same model, same input. But different
output.
Here I don't mean the wording different.
I mean semantically different output.
You might be thinking that's the
stochastic nature of LM.
Hold on to that thought. Let's look at a
few concrete examples.
So here imagine you're giving a task for
sentiment analysis where we're supposed
to label each of the review of the hotel
either positive or negative.
This is typical NLP task. And today's LM
is really good at this.
However, there's one problem.
When you pipe this input to the same LM
model,
occasionally you will see different
verdict coming out of it when you run
multiple times.
That means a single evaluation run
didn't tell you the whole story.
You need to repeat your
evaluation multiple times
in order to get a holistic picture
by the average over the different runs
results.
And this sounds like a technical
inconvenience,
but the reality
is
is way more problematic than just
inconvenience.
Let me show you an example in a
different domain in cybersecurity.
Imagine you are a security analyst where
your day-to-day job is
triage the security alerts
and decide whether it's malicious that
you need to take certain actions
to stop the attack
or it's false alarm, meaning it's
actually benign, which you could ignore.
So, here example alert you got is
there's a failed logging attempt to
Gmail account detected from suspicious
IP.
And if we give such similar task to this
one to AI agent and run it different
times,
you will see sometimes it stay
consistently benign, sometimes it stay
consistently suspicious across different
runs.
However, there are cases where it
flip-flop
between benign and suspicious.
Now,
your customer will have a difficulty
using such product
because they will wonder, "Which one
should I trust?"
So, the inconsistency
is causing a trust issue
in your product.
Imagine if you were in a POC bake-off,
one vendor
give the consistent wording all the time
while
the other
vendor
have this flip-flop wording.
You can imagine which one would win the
deal.
Now, I'm pretty sure you want to solve
this problem.
First, we have we have to figure out
where the inconsistency come from.
The good news is
the data points tend to flip-flop
actually concentrate around
the decision boundary, the so-called
gray zone.
Let me illustrate with the earlier
example.
Here
in the sentiment analysis, we have two
reviews.
The first one
actually no matter how many times you
run through the LM model, it will always
give you the positive label.
In this case, it's pretty obvious is
the review is super positive.
However, the second case is the one tend
to flip.
If we look closer,
it's kind of on the boundary.
Sometimes there's certain word is kind
of a relative positive,
but sometimes there's a little bit
negative.
In this case,
you'll find that even human experts
will have a disagreement on these cases.
In fact, there's no right or wrong
answer. It really depends on particular
company's policy and their preference.
For hotel thinking that the
such review is not something I can do to
improve the memorial
kind of experience,
memorable experience. Then, that mean
not to label as naughty because there's
nothing I can do.
But some hotel might care about it and
want to label them as natives so they
can improve.
So, that comes down
your preference.
Let's look the other cybersecurity
example.
Here
is another case on the boundary. And why
it's in the boundary is
here there's a few
attempts.
Indeed, there's attacker knocking on the
door.
But
attacker might not getting yet.
So, for enterprise customers who always
have attacker knocking on the door,
well, if they haven't getting in the
environment, they don't want to worry
about it. Otherwise, they will be
flooded by this type of alerts. There's
nothing they need to do because they are
blocked outside already.
However, if the attacker do manage to
get the correct password and pass MFA
and do manage getting the environment,
then it become very seriously and you
need to take certain actions.
So,
almost similarly at the beginning
behavior, but very different outcome and
different response needed.
Depends on whether it's truly attack or
attacker is still outside.
So, here
whether we label them malicious or
benign depends on company preference
whether they wanted to be notified about
such situation.
So, again, this is the example where it
depends on your preference.
And additional information to
disambiguate between the two different
scenarios.
So from these two very different
domains, you will see that
actually
the data points tend to flip-flop.
Are the one close to the decision
boundary
where
it need your clarity
to disambiguate which side it should
really belongs to.
So these data points are where human
experts tend to make a mistake.
And the traditional machine learning
classifier will also struggle with.
So in other words
it's not your AI agent's fault.
Your AI
agent simply point out the ambiguity
that already exists.
So
now we know where the root cause of the
inconsistent is.
The next step is identify
where exactly they are.
Who are they?
And fix them.
Surprisingly and not surprised
the solution to identify the gray zone
actually exists already in machine
learning.
And it's called active learning.
So
the idea of active learning is
you have a lot of data point to be
labeled.
Imagine you'd have your initial model
and you put it in production, maybe in
the monitor mode.
And you wanted to check the quality.
But you don't have bandwidth to check
all of them.
Otherwise, it lose a point of having
agent to do the work.
But you still want to identify where the
model
didn't do well.
And then active learning is to find a
way
to select
the data points where
tend to make mistake.
And that's where it tells you
where to pull your attention.
So let's go over the traditional
um machine learning models active
learning pipeline and see how is
different in the case of the new LM or
AI agent error.
So first, you train your initial model
and then you make predictions on the
unlabeled data set. It could be the
production
online data.
And then from there, you see there's
certain cases where the model wasn't
sure because the probability is close to
2.5.
And those data points are the high
informational one
that your model is going to learn the
most.
The uncertainty is a type of the signal
to tell you where the model tend to make
a mistake.
Another popular type of way to figure
out the problematic one is query by
committee, meaning that it by a few
different models or even same model
multiple times and then you identify the
disagreement. And that's where the model
tend to make a mistake as well and
that's where you need human
clarification on label so the model can
learn it from.
The after you
surface these problematic data points
and for human to take a second look to
make sure the label is actually correct
or
do we doesn't need additional
information to dis
ambiguate those cases meaning adding new
features.
And then you can add those label data
set or potentially additional features
to the next round of training.
Then you retrain the model and then
proceed
uh continue this cycle.
So then you can see in this particular
active learning cycle
you spend very little uh amount or at
least in other way it's very efficient
way to identify the problematic data
points and spend your attention on those
point where your model tend to learn the
most.
So that's the traditional one. The good
news is the LM way
is
not very different.
There's a major two part which we need
some refinement. One is on this
selection strategy. The other part is
about retraining.
On the selection strategy one
um here we suggest you use the one about
identify disagreement.
At least from what we have tried so far
the uncertainty score from LM is not
very reliable.
It's kind of a LM model doesn't know
what it doesn't know. So when it's very
confident it doesn't mean that it was
the it would is correct. So that
However, the the disagreement from
different runs or from different models
actually give you a more reliable signal
where the model actually
not sure about its verdict and it need
human guidance.
And then after you identify this group
or the
uh
discriminant and need attention, you
label them and provide a feedback like
what you did before.
Then afterwards,
you might be thinking, "Oh, time to
retrain the model."
Yes or no.
Yes, one option is retrain the model,
but
fine-tuning model is expensive.
Here, we are proposing
a more lighter weight solution, easier
to iterate.
It's about augment your agent with
semantic and episodic memory.
Let's use the previous example to
illustrate what I mean here.
Um
as we talked about, in this case, the
attempt to flip, it's mainly missing the
information
about you a particular company policy or
preference.
Here, we can add it to the um
the knowledge base.
If this customer complain about
something outside hotel's control, then
classify as positive because you don't
want to pay attention to this.
And then in the cybersecurity example,
something similar, you can put in in
that the password spray, meaning that
the attacker trying to guess your
password and
try it with different times, even fail,
and continuously.
So, if without successful logging, then
that should be benign. But, in contrast,
if it succeed with final logging,
then that should be malicious.
So, here you actually identify the
additional information to help
disambiguate the two and then label them
separately. And that's a clarity
that help your model to learn.
Also, help your human experts to label
more consistently.
So, this type of domain knowledge
sharpen your decision boundary.
And also, help the human beings.
And this type of knowledge is like
factual knowledge, is part of actually
belong to your semantic memory.
And this is in contrast with the
episodic memory.
Episodic memory is in the case where
you
haven't get around to distill the
reasoning behind the earlier case why it
should be
on malicious or the benign side.
Instead, you said that
I have seen these similar cases before
and it was labeled as benign. And let me
leverage those past similar cases and
they made a decision accordingly.
And the advantage of the this episodic
memory way is it's relatively
automatically. It has less human
intervention. I mean, the human
intervention was done in the past
already when during when you're doing a
job
online, um
you can reference them,
at least your AI agent can reference
them automatically. They can making
decisions without waiting for you to
distill the reasoning and putting in the
semantic knowledge.
So, the idea is that the
identify a similar case to the one under
examination and then leverage their past
decision as a reference.
And then imagine there's a new case
which is coming in the middle, doesn't
belong to any of past group, and that's
the one you still need a human
attention.
And this is how also
um where episodic memory resolve
recurring case
automatically.
And this particular useful in the case
of cyber security alerts because a lot
of noise
especially those false positive noise
are the one keep recurring. And that's
the one are the low hanging fruit you
can automate away.
And with that human review
which is a precious attention and
bandwidth you have, now you can
concentrate on those where episodic
memory failed to address.
And this is also how
we chose between semantic memory and
episodic memory. The two are actually
not contradicting. In fact, they are
complementary. Basically, you use
episodic memory to address those
recurring situations automatically.
And then for what remains still
reflecting after the reference from the
past or no reference to be able to use,
then you pass on to human review.
And then human review distill the domain
knowledge and put it in the semantic
memory to be used next time.
So here we talk about a solution
actually brings three benefits.
First,
we identify these data point near the
decision boundary
and use the domain knowledge in semantic
memory and this past similar case in the
episodic memory, we're able to improve
the the consistency
significantly.
So, now you have a more trustworthy
AI agent for your user to use.
And two other byproduct of this solution
is
you have a very efficient quality
control.
You don't need to check every
agent output, but instead a subset of
them, which
your algorithm uh active learning think
is potentially problematic, and you
check them,
either provide additional information or
clarify the label,
and your model will learn from there.
So,
most importantly,
your
labeling effort
is very small, but high return.
Last but not least,
now you are gathering your customer
feedback along this way.
You not only have a trustworthy
consistent model and high efficacy one,
you also have one adapt to your customer
environment.
I'm pretty sure your customer will love
your product if you
your AI agent listen to them and adapt
to them.
So, here are some experiment results
from uh real data points. So, here we
collect uh
93 alerts,
cybersecurity alerts, and then we run
them three times.
If without the solution we are proposing
here,
a quarter of them will flip-flop the
verdict.
In contrast, after applying our solution
or using episodic memory,
about 15% of them
become consistent.
However, there's still 10% of them
remaining inconsistent. They still flip.
Sometimes because there's no reference,
similar cases in past paper used.
Sometimes even there's a reference to be
used, they
still disagree after the second thought.
But not a problem. The episodic memory
do the automatic
lock down all the inconsistency for 15%.
The remaining 10% human review and
provide the additional knowledge to
disambiguate
those tricky cases.
After that,
you also adapt to the
customer environment that you want to
learn.
So,
the three takeaways
that I hope you have after this talk is
number one,
inconsistency isn't usually your model
problem.
Stop blaming your model, but instead
focus your energy on label issue and
potentially insufficient information and
help your AI agent with this additional
clarity.
Second,
the model disagreement isn't a bug,
but feature.
Treat each disagreement as an
opportunity for your model to learn.
Third,
fine-tuning isn't your only option.
Augment your agent with semantic and
episodic memory.
I hope you enjoy seeing your model
keep improving
and adapting to your customer
environment.
Last but not least, I want to thanks to
my colleagues and wonderful friends at
Data Dog. Special thanks to Ditun and
Harsh, Anusha, and Stefan, Saeed, and
Mati to give me a lot of enjoyable
discussions and helped me to clarify
some of the
um
the concept.
And also, thank you for everyone in the
Beats Secured Analyst team to make this
journey enjoyable.
And thank you for listening. Hope you
will enjoy
training your model and having it
improving.
Thank you. Bye.